liberty university says jerry falwell
jr offered to resign as president of the
evangelical christian school but then
changed his mind it comes amid
allegations that falwell
and his wife had a sexual relationship
involving a pool attendant they met
more than eight years ago fall while a
prominent evangelical christian leader
is the son of liberty university's
founder he reportedly denies having any
role in the affair jerica duncan is
following this story
tarika do we know why falwell took back
his resignation
you know it is still unclear anthony at
this time as to what that was about the
university said that falwell agreed to
resign and then it was later on
yesterday
that falwell was telling reporters that
he did not have plans to leave
permanently questions about jerry
falwell junior's leadership at liberty
university in lynchburg virginia
come after john carlo granda claimed in
an interview with reuters
that he had a years-long sexual
relationship involving falwell's wife
and the evangelical leader granda said
he was 20 when he met the fall wells
while working as a pool attendant at a
miami beach hotel
in march of 2012. grandis said their
relationship continued until 2018
and involved him having sex with becky
falwell while
jerry falwell looked on granda shared
evidence with reuters to support his
account
including this phone call his new thing
is like telling me every time he hooks
up with people like
i don't have feelings or something
not trying to do that but falwell's
version of the story is different
falwell issued a statement to the
washington examiner saying
his wife had an inappropriate personal
relationship
with the man they had first met while on
vacation and later went into business
with
he went on to write he was not involved
in the affair but the man began
threatening to publicly reveal the
relationship
unless falwell and his wife agreed to
pay him substantial monies
we must unite behind donald trump and
mike pence
falwell who spoke at the 2016 republican
national convention
has been a fierce supporter of president
trump his wife becky is an advisory
board member of women for trump
and appeared in an interview with
president trump's daughter-in-law
laura we look forward to 2020
and winning and making america great
again
and again and again falwell was already
on an indefinite leave of absence from
the university
after he posted this photo on social
media with his pants unzipped
he said the photo was taken at a costume
party i'm sure
there are a lot of christians even those
who maybe sent their children to liberty
university attended liberty university
support donald trump who are disgusted
by this
john fia a history professor at messiah
university
studies evangelical christianity within
evangelicalism
you know you could make racist comments
you could make you know uh
you could lie you could do a bunch of
things that are
unbiblical but but sexual sin has been
sort of the primary uh the greatest sin
it's been this way a long time in
evangelicalism and jerry falwell
certainly
cross that line if this reuters story
is true cbs news has reached out to the
fall walls and john carlo
granda we have not heard back yet but
the board of trustees at liberty
university is expected to meet today on
a conference call
to discuss the matter gail oh boy so
many layers of wrong on that story
starting with the alleged affair if it's
true with the pool attendant who was 20
something at the time to mr falwell
allegedly looking on
just they have a lot to discuss i've
seen a pool attendant all they ever gave
me was a towel
that's very interesting story thank you
very much tarika